este mi abuelo enrique el que está
sentado y al lado soy yo con la típica
cara de trance que suelo tener cuando me
toca ponerme una corbata mi abuelo era
médico cirujano y nunca me voy a olvidar
del día en que me dijo un cirujano es
una persona que tiene la vida de alguien
en sus manos
cuando mi amo le empezó a operar aún no
se había descubierto la penicilina por
lo cual el destino de la operación y del
paciente no dependía totalmente del
cirujano sino de las posibilidades de
que hubiera alguna infección dando
vueltas
mi abuelo vivió un momento bisagra para
la medicina porque a partir de la
aparición de los antibióticos no sólo se
pudieron realizar operaciones sino que
se pusieron cuidar accidentes realizar
trasplantes solamente en la segunda
guerra mundial la penicilina permitió
salvar las vidas de 6 millones de
heridos
aquí estoy yo con mis viejos en mi
primer navidad mi viajero visitador
médico y el principal producto que
vendía su laboratorio precisamente un
antibiótico y como podrán ver ahí yo
estoy contento si no estoy más distraído
por las bolas del árbol de navidad que
por los juguetes estoy contento con los
mismos y con los regalos pero se me ve
saludable y rollizo y eso es porque en
mi casa había una muy buena cultura del
cuidado de la salud como se ve acá no
pretendo que lo lean pero es un apunte
que hizo mi viejo que dejó mi mamá con
los horarios en que tenía que tomar la
mamadera y que me tenían que dar los
remedios
pero lo que les quiero decir es que
tanto mis viejos como yo vivimos en un
mundo en el cual los antibióticos eran
parte de nuestra cultura cotidiana y ya
nadie más vivía con el temor de morir de
una infección lamentablemente hoy en el
siglo 21 el escenario es completamente
distinto porque las bacterias están
volviéndose resistentes a los
antibióticos que están dejando de
funcionar solamente en los eeuu 2
millones de personas se infectan por año
con bacterias resistentes antibióticos y
23.000 de ellos mueren a causa de estas
infecciones
entonces qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
y uno pregunta yo que soy investigador
lo cual es una profesión lo
suficientemente cool como para que me
inviten a dar una charla te de c's pero
que no garantiza que me inviten un asado
y hable de estas cosas
en mi laboratorio tratamos de entender
de qué manera algunas bacterias se
convirtieron en súper bacterias es decir
bacterias que son capaz de resistir a
todos los tipos de antibióticos y ver de
qué manera se pueden frenar y aquí es
como uno piensa generalmente que se ve
una superbacteria de microscopio aparece
estos monstruos babeando llenos de
colmillos pero la realidad de detección
de las superbacterias no es tan así y
eso lo aprendí el día que nos trajeron
al laboratorio un aislado clínico de un
paciente de 7 años que tenía meningitis
bacteriana internado en el clemente
alvarez que murió porque ningún
antibiótico podía tratarlo
entonces hoy quiero compartir un par de
preguntas con ustedes cómo es que
llegamos a esta situación y de qué
manera podemos salir de esta
la resistencia a los antibióticos es una
consecuencia inevitable del uso de los
antibióticos pensemos que la producción
mundial de antibióticos es de 100 mil
toneladas por año esto equivale al peso
de un crucero de 300 metros de largo y 7
pisos de alto dos terceras partes de
esta producción se dedican para el
mejoramiento de animales
solamente el resto se utiliza para la
salud humana y de esa parte que se
utiliza para salud humana la mitad de se
usa para tratar resfríos o gripes que
son enfermedades virales y que no
necesitan antibióticos
esto significa que año a año estamos
usando decenas de miles de antibióticos
para cualquier cosa diseminando los en
el ambiente
y en ese proceso lo que estamos haciendo
es seleccionar a las bacterias más aptas
para sobrevivir o sea que estamos
acelerando su evolución y ya que
hablamos de evolución voy a traer un
ejemplo familiar para todos que es el
caso de la chita que es el animal más
rápido que existe en este planeta y fue
seleccionada tan rápida por la evolución
porque de esa manera puede atrapar a su
presa y no se muere de hambre
por su parte las gacelas que son presas
normales de las chicas
han desarrollado otros mecanismos como
correr en zigzag saltar o tener más
resistencia porque de otra manera como
corren más lentos que las chicas
terminarían en su escena
el juego que nosotros estamos jugando
hoy en día es bastante similar entonces
nos tenemos que preguntar de qué manera
nosotros estamos corriendo esta carrera
de evolución con las bacterias acá vamos
a ver un experimento el brote de roy
quiso ni en harvard en el cual en esa
mesa que están viendo se siembran
bacterias en la punta en la punta de esa
mesa se puede ver inicialmente donde
dice 0 no hay antibiótico y yendo hacia
el centro va aumentando paulatinamente
la cantidad de antibiótico
cuando sembramos las bacterias
originalmente
vemos que crecen obviamente en la zona
donde no hay antibiótico pero luego sólo
es cuestión de tiempo y esperar que
estas bacterias comiencen a mutar a
adaptarse y crecer hasta las zonas
internas este vídeo que están viendo las
muestras de qué manera en sólo 11 días
las bacterias logran adaptarse una
concentración mil veces más alta de
antibióticos y cuál es nuestra velocidad
nosotros tardamos 15 años para
desarrollar un antibiótico nuevo
entonces significa que no hay forma que
le podamos ganar esta carrera de las
bacterias y esto es así porque si
pensamos en lo que es la evolución en la
tierra y queremos representar la
historia del planeta en 12 horas
nosotros seres humanos llegamos a la
tierra en el último minuto los
dinosaurios aparecieron a las 11 hace
sobre una hora las plantas de tierra
aparecieron a las 10 y las bacterias que
se estarán preguntando aparecieron a las
esto significa que vivimos en un mundo
que ha sido moldeado por y para las
bacterias y de manera muy soberbia
creemos que estar en un mundo
antropocéntrico entonces no hay manera
de ganarles
y no solo que son mucho más viejas sino
que son más si pensamos en la población
mundial que es de 7.400 millones de
personas la población de bacterias como
pueden ver es muchísimo más grande y no
solo son más sino que pueden estar en
los lugares más extremos que puedan
imaginarse porque las bacterias pueden
vivir en un game srl a 90 grados de
temperatura pueden vivir en los polos
pueden vivir en desiertos y hasta la
casa blanca si se imagina y así como
están en todos lados están en nosotros
en nuestro cuerpo cada uno de nosotros
tienen nuestro cuerpo más células de
bacterias que células humanas entonces
nosotros nos podemos preguntar que somos
somos bacterias o somos humanos nos van
a matar no es así y es todo lo contrario
precisamente el conjunto de bacterias
que están en nuestro organismo nos
permiten estar saludables ese conjunto
de bacterias se llama microbioma humano
y nos provee nutrientes entren a nuestro
sistema natural de defensas no hagáis
una la digestión y hasta modula nuestros
estados de ánimo
es un ejemplo excelente de naturaleza de
convivencia dentro de la diversidad
y así como antes empecé comentándoles de
las bacterias como supervillanos ahora
les voy a hablar de las bacterias como
superhéroes esto que ven acá se llama
clostridium difficile y es una infección
intestinal que no puede tratar ningún
antibiótico la forma de tratarlo es a
través de un plan de un trasplante de
materia fecal sic de kaká para
traducirlo más fácilmente de un paciente
sano de esa manera todo el microbioma
del paciente sano puede colonizar el
intestino enfermo y exterminar a
clostridium difficile otro ejemplo que
podemos ver de las bacterias como
superhéroes es tomando estos dos
pequeños ratoncitos ovi el gordito y
lenny el flaquito estos dos son mellizos
y decir que son genéticamente idénticos
no se pueden pensar que estuvo demasiado
tiempo en el mcdonald's mientras que
ellen hizo la dieta de la manzana pero
no estuvieron los dos exactamente bajo
el mismo régimen de alimentación la
única diferencia es que no vi tuvo un
trasplante de caca de un humano obeso
recibiendo toda su microbiota
recibe un trasplante de caca de un
humano flaco y como podemos hacer para
no complicarle más la vida a ovi los
ponemos juntos en una jaula y los
ratones tienen esa saludable costumbre
de comerse la caca del otro
con lo cual si obi se come la caca del
en y termina el viajando
ahora yo no quisiera que con esto
ustedes piensen si tienen como un
mensaje que con la caca nos vamos a
salvar y que con la caca vamos a
adelgazar
y también se dan cuenta en función de
estas cosas porque no me invitan a los
calzados a hablar de lo que yo hago
y para que no se lleven la caca a sus
casas porque les cuento esto los quiero
hacer reflexionar de que nosotros
vivimos en un mundo en que tanto las
bacterias como los antibióticos son
parte de nuestros recursos naturales y
que con las bacterias tenemos una
convivencia dentro de la diversidad al
que son valores culturales pero que
también existe dentro de la naturaleza y
entonces nosotros tenemos que cuidar y
preservar los antibióticos
no hay forma que nosotros les podamos
ganar la carrera a las bacterias ya
vieron las velocidades distintas que
tenemos ahora que no podamos ganar la
carrera no quiere decir que no podamos
ganar la maratón entonces la forma de
cuidar los antibióticos es administrar
los recursos en el tiempo como en una
maratón por eso quiero invitarlos a
ustedes para que conjuntamente
aboguemos en primer lugar para que no se
administren innecesariamente
antibióticos a los animales ya que
existen otras alternativas más amigables
con el ambiente y que no causan
resistencia
en segundo lugar que no se vendan
antibióticos como si fueran caramelos
sin prescripción médica y ustedes dirán
que puedo hacerlo porque estas dos
acciones tienen sin duda que ver con
políticas públicas hay mucho que
nosotros podemos hacer y podemos hacerlo
ya mismo
en primer lugar si tenemos un resfrío
si estamos congestionados por favor no
tomen antibióticos gratuitamente en
segundo lugar si un médico nos prescribe
un antibiótico y nos dice que lo tenemos
que tomar cada ocho horas durante siete
días no interrumpamos la toma ya sabemos
lo rápido que se reproducen las
bacterias cuando le damos la oportunidad
entonces por eso respetemos esas tomas y
aquí quiero volver al cronograma de toma
de mamaderas de mi viejo y me permito
compartir algo tan personal porque me
importa y porque quiero que a ustedes le
importe
mi abuelo vive un momento bisagra en la
historia de la humanidad a partir del
cual cambiaron las expectativas de vida
de todos
ahora corremos el riesgo de estar en
otro momento bisagra porque los
antibióticos que salvaron millones de
vidas durante 70 años están dejando de
funcionar
por eso yo los quiero invitar a todos a
salvar los antibióticos entre todos
podemos salvar los antibióticos entre
todos podemos salvar vidas recuerden que
tenemos la vida de muchas personas en
nuestras mismas